welcome back a judge is allowing a
lawsuit to move forward against epic
games which says the video game fortnite
is specifically designed to get kids
addicted to playing it the filing is on
behalf of parents in Canada and they say
that their kids are so addicted that
they're not even eating showering or
sleeping in fact one parent said that
their child played more than 7 700 times
in two years with a minimum of three
hours of play every day while the court
didn't agree with the assertion that
epics games intentionally made the game
addictive it did concede that fortnite
may in fact be addictive and epic games
likely knew that the online video game
has more than 250 million registered
users worldwide many of them children
teenagers epics games Epic Games says
it's the parents responsibility to quote
supervise their children's digital
experience and they plan to fight this
lawsuit in court Brian lawyers involved
in the suit of compared video games to
the tobacco industry they say the
developers created something that is
potentially harmful without warning
people about it
all right as long crime dailies Canadian
co-host and new father I guess it's only
fitting for me to discuss this eh all
right well this case may stay north of
the Border but it's still interesting to
look at like me it may move South so the
lawsuit hinges on the world health
organizations or who designation that
video games are addicting and is a
mental health disorder and fortnite
being one of the biggest games since it
came out in July of 2017. it makes sense
that it would be a target of a lawsuit
it's addicting I've played I've seen
kids play it and there are no
disclaimers as to how addicting it is
but the makers of fortnite are saying
that there are a number of parental
controls in the game to limit how people
play and they're saying that's enough
and they're leaving it to the parents to
regulate how much their child does or
doesn't play that seems to be the
argument and that there's enough
protection now the United States and
their courts don't use the who
guidelines for mental health diagnosis
they use the diagnostic and statistical
manual or dsms and they don't consider
gaming a mental health disorder but that
could change and bring this case to the
U.S so it makes it interesting to see
how it plays out we're going to
obviously keep eyes on this case but
like you said the major argument is who
is the one at fault here and and of
course it's a video game it's supposed
to be addicting but it's meant to be the
parents and the players to regulate how
much they play right not the game for
making it less entertaining see Terry I
think there's more at stake right if the
lawsuit prevails couldn't it just open
the floodgates for other similar claims
maybe against other games or other kinds
of things absolutely I don't think it
should Prevail because if it did it
means that almost anything that you get
addicted to you can be sued for making
something more interesting and more you
know exciting for someone to play and if
you take it to its logical conclusion
that means everything from any social
media platform any game online even you
could say you get addicted to rock
climbing so I definitely think that this
case is not good for the industry and I
think think it is stretching you know
the old adage that you can sue anybody
anytime for anything that is what is
happening here you have to make the
parents more responsible you have to
make the people playing the game more
responsible you can't expect any person
who is manufacturing something like this
not to make it in a an addictive fashion
I don't know I think there's something
to it because when I was you guys were
talking I was watching I was kind of
glued to the screen Brian Terry thanks
so much thanks for everybody for joining
us here on the daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America